congratulations are in order for one of
our favorite celebs here at ET I gotta
say I love having her as my birthday
twin Chrissy Teigen born on November 30
and today she turns 33 and we have so
many reasons for loving Chrissy but
really what they're all wrapped up and
we realized is this this umbrella of
keeping it real
Chrissy keeps it real oh we've got a
little birthday celebration that just
came in by the way from her amazing
husband John Legend said it's Chrissy's
birthday I love you my queen about ten
minutes ago yes she's all of our Queens
she keeps it real and we wanted Cheers
Chrissy on her birthday we are looking
back at some of her realest moments of
the past year I truly just do the best I
can do for my body because I know that
I'm not gonna ever have those curves and
that ass and that waistline that's just
not my body and I'm fine with that
oh yeah I wanna eat jack-in-the-box I
guess these just aren't gonna go away
this is many-body we sleep naked but you
probably but you probably knew that this
is my skin on my period look at it so
angry
and I lost my voice but I ordered for
chicken soft taco Suman del Taco and
these are clearly a hardshell tacos
which is fine but I didn't order it
I'm like I am completely at food peace
right now I just fell down the stairs I
think of really mean things and I'm like
I can't say that so I say it out loud to
everyone around me and then I type
something a little tape
[Music]
[Applause]